[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy con la
primera de dos entrevistas que haremos
para entender la situación política de
bolivia la conversación es contigo parís
embajador o boliviano ante la onu y ex
ministro de relaciones exteriores en el
gobierno de evo morales y próximamente
hablaremos con la oposición para ver las
dos caras de la moneda bienvenido señor
pari y empecemos hablando por favor de
la detención preventiva de la ex
presidenta interina jeanine áñez como se
puede entender que cuando ella estaba en
el poder la fiscalía acusó a evo
morales- de terrorismo y ahora que
regresa el gobierno de izquierda la
procesan a ella por el mismo delito
adelante el ministerio público es un
tema que corresponde a la justicia
boliviana y en ese marco para algún tema
que un tema pendiente hubo una demanda
pendiente que se presentó y pues el
poder ejecutivo de acuerdo al orden del
órgano judicial por la detención
preventiva se realizan las
investigaciones por un golpe de estado
que se perpetró que a todas luces es es
evidente en bolivia hay 36 vidas que se
han perdido y todavía las familias
esperan conocer la verdad y esperan
tener una respuesta que esperan tener
justicia por lo que la causa del golpe
de estado
mire la oposición asegura que tanto el
fiscal general fausto juan lanchipa como
el procurador general y wilfredo chávez
son cercanos al oficialista movimiento
al socialismo más y la oea también ha
denunciado injerencias políticas en la
justicia que están haciendo las
diferentes ramas de poder en bolivia
para garantizar el proceso de agnès para
que sea justo e imparcial
la fiscalía es la misma la misma
fiscalía que en su momento estuvo en el
gobierno de años fue a la misma fiscalía
que emitió las detenciones contra el
gobierno del presidente contra los a las
ex autoridades del gobierno
en ese marco pues es la misma fiscalía
que trabajó justamente con el gobierno
que en ese momento se tenía segundo la
oea no tiene moral el secretario general
de la organización de los estados
americanos no tienen moral no tiene
ninguna credibilidad y no tiene ninguna
autoridad para referirse a bolivia
porque es uno de los actores principales
para el golpe de estado es uno de los es
uno de los actores para el derrocamiento
del gobierno constitucional y para
llevar a bolivia una nueva crisis
política que se dio en el año 2019
señor ha habido muchas críticas por el
proceso primero la trasladaron de
prisión en la madrugada y de manera
sorpresiva después un juez aumentó su
permanencia en la cárcel a petición de
la fiscalía y de la procuraduría y
finalmente no la remitieron a una
clínica como pedía su defensa a qué se
deben estos cambios
está claro que las autoridades
encargadas del régimen penitenciario han
hecho la evaluación correspondiente con
médicos especializados y en función a
eso es que se está procediendo hay una
institución especializada que en este
caso es el ebit quien hace estas
evaluaciones médicas les está por
decidir de acuerdo a norma existe
también una declaración voluntaria de
ella donde dice que ella acepta
voluntariamente a ser trasladada del
penal de obrajes al penal de miraflores
así que no se está haciendo nada al
margen de la ley se está respetando en
absoluto todos los derechos que tiene la
detenida pero además está cumpliendo con
todo lo que establece la constitución
y desde las protestas en 2019 se han
dado múltiples manifestaciones tanto a
favor como en contra de las políticas de
morales e ideales y ahora miles de
personas marchan en contra de la
detención de la ex presidenta cómo se
podría ayudar a reducir la polarización
que existe en el país
los miles quienes marchan son son grupos
pequeños que pertenecen claramente a
partidos políticos identificados son
partidos de oposición y obviamente que
estarán ahí para líderes políticos son
culpables
desde el derrocamiento de un gobierno
constitucional y lo que ahora
corresponde es que se pueda buscar
justicia corresponde que las familias
que han perdido a un miedo a un miembro
de su familia puedan conocer la verdad y
puedan saber acerca de los hechos y es
en ese marco que se está llevando
adelante los procesos no lo lleva el
órgano ejecutivo lo está llevando
adelante el ministerio público que es
una instancia absolutamente
independiente del poder ejecutivo lo
lleva adelante la justicia boliviana y
creo que lo que corresponde es que tanto
los organismos internacionales como los
diferentes países puedan hacer
seguimiento pero fundamentalmente la
decisión le corresponde al estado
boliviano y la decisión de cosas
bueno solamente para aclarar señor pari
cuando hablábamos de miles de
manifestantes decíamos que eran de parte
y parte gracias a ustedes por estar con
nosotros en france24 y continúen ustedes
también con toda nuestra programación
[Música]